do these men are actors they're bullets
are blanks but in propaganda Warfare
they are true Warriors and in Russia
there is no doubt that they are winning
this is a touring performance here in
the town of Vladimir the audience filled
with young military cadets and men in
uniforms
immersive theater to glorify Russia's
role in Ukraine and vilify the West
[Music]
thank you
part theater part film much of its shot
on location in donbass on territory
captured by the Russians
and it is a wild tale of Bio Labs of
alleged Ukrainian Terror plots to blow
up a chemical plant and place the blame
on Russia of heroic Russian Special
Forces who saved the day against
drug-addled Nazis
and of big bad Americans running the
show
spend some time do you understand what's
at stake videos
[Music]
when the narrative is this compelling
and this emotive it's no wonder so many
people believe it is
foreign
city named after Vladimir the Great the
grand Prince of Kiev who United Kiev and
Russ and converted it to Christianity
do you think Vladimir Putin will ever be
as great as this Vladimir
the loss of Carson spun is unfortunate
but necessary sold as a chance to
regroup to a people used to group think
it's been nine months now since Vladimir
Putin launched his invasion and in that
time people's attitudes if anything
seemed to have hardened there seems to
be an Ever deepening conviction
reinforced almost by the latest setbacks
that this loss of territory loss of life
must be for a reason
the endless online petitions to Vladimir
Putin this one by families from the
Vladimir region demand better kit and
training for their men but they won't
speak to Western media and it's hard to
find many who will for them we are still
the enemy and they are still Patriots
and so Behind These Walls the next
tranche of men prepare for the front
line belief in their cause one of the
strongest weapons they have
Diana Magnus Sky News Vladimir Russia